Greg Gage: ¿A quién no le encantaría destacarse en un examen de geografía,
recordando la ubicación de todos los países en un mapa,
o evitar la situación vergonzosa de olvidar de repente
el nombre de la persona que tienes frente a ti?
Resulta que la memoria, como los otros músculos del cuerpo,
puede fortificarse y mejorarse.
Pero en lugar de practicar con tarjetas de memoria,
puede haber una manera interesante de alterar nuestra memoria
mientras dormimos.
(Música)
¿Por qué dormimos?
Es una pregunta que viene desde los albores de la civilización.
Y aunque no sepamos la respuesta exacta,
hay varias teorías muy buenas sobre por qué necesitamos dormir.
Mientras dormimos, el cerebro transfiere la memoria de corto plazo
experimentada durante el día
a la memoria de largo plazo.
El proceso se llama la consolidación de la memoria
y mediante esta teoría los científicos se preguntan
si podemos realzar unas memorias más que otras.
Salió un artículo hace poco en la revista "Science"
de Ken Paller y sus colegas de Northwestern
que sugiere que esto pueda ser verdad.
Y nos despertó la curiosidad.
Joud está haciendo una versión casera de esta prueba
para ver si podemos mejorar la memoria con el uso de sonidos y del sueño.
Joud, ¿cómo se comprueba si se puede mejorar la memoria con el sueño?
Joud Mar’i: Necesitamos un sujeto humano.
[Paso 1: Jugar a algo]
Tenemos un juego de memoria instalado en un iPad.
Y pedimos que nuestro sujeto lo juegue
y que recuerde las imágenes y dónde aparecen en la pantalla.
GG: Es como un juego de la memoria que se jugaba de niño.
Asociamos a cada imagen un sonido que la representa.
JM: Si ves la imagen de un auto, por ejemplo,
escucharás el sonido de un motor.
(Sonido de arranque de motor)
GG: Justo antes de dormir, te haremos una prueba
para ver qué tan bien recuerdas donde están las imágenes.
Cada vez que ves la imagen, vas a oír el sonido.
Ahora, el experimento.
Vas a dormir la siesta.
[Paso 2: Duerme la siesta]
Y mientras duermes, grabaremos tu electroencefalografía.
JM: Esperamos hasta que entre en lo que se llama el sueño de onda lenta,
la etapa más profunda del sueño y en la que es muy difícil despertarse.
GG: Espera.
Un poco de información sobre el sueño:
hay cuatro fases del sueño; las fases más ligeras y REM,
pero estamos interesados en lo que se llama el sueño de onda lenta,
cuyo nombre viene de las señales eléctricas llamadas ondas deltas
que grabamos del cerebro.
Esta es la fase del sueño en la que los científicos creen
que puede ocurrir la consolidación de la memoria.
En esta etapa de sueño profundo vamos a hacer algo
que no sabes que vamos a hacer.
JM: Aquí se complica la cosa. Empezamos a dar las pistas.
[Paso 3: Tocar sonidos]
(Sonido de arranque de motor)
GG: ¿Tocas todas las pistas?
JM: No. Solo tocamos la mitad de ellas, para ver si hay una diferencia.
GG: Entonces, tu hipótesis es que
va a poder recordar mejor el sonido que escuchaba mientras dormía.
JM: Sí, exacto.
[Paso 4: Juega de nuevo]
GG: Cuando te despiertas y juegas de nuevo,
¿juegas mejor o peor que antes de la siesta?
Encontramos que si te tocamos una pista mientras dormías
por ejemplo, de un auto,
recordarías la posición de ese auto cuando te despertaste de nuevo.
Pero si no te tocamos la pista mientras dormías,
por ejemplo, de una guitarra,
sería menos probable que recordaras la guitarra cuando te despertaste.
¿Recordaron mejor las memorias con pistas que las sin pistas,
aunque no se acuerdan haberlas escuchado?
JM: Sí, exacto, les preguntamos.
GG: Sabes que están durmiendo, no pueden escuchar,
se despiertan y recuerdan mejor que cuando no tocas pistas.
GG: Es increíble. JM: Como la magia.
GG: Joud condujo el experimento con 12 personas,
con resultados significativos.
No es que recuerdes las cosas mejor; es que las olvidas menos.
Era muy escéptico cuando escuché
que podría irte mejor en una prueba de memoria
solo por tocar sonidos mientras duermes.
Pero replicamos estos experimentos.
Los datos y los recuerdos que recolectamos durante el día son muy frágiles,
y se pierden y olvidan fácilmente.
Pero al reactivarlos mientras dormimos, aun sin ser conscientes de ello,
parece que podríamos hacerlos más estables y menos propensos a olvido.
Es bastante increíble.
Nuestros cerebros siguen activos, aun cuando nosotros, no.
Entonces, si eres un poco distraído como yo,
quizás la solución sea un par de auriculares y un sofá cómodo.